今日は還暦が黒くなりました和美社長です皆さん不審者
あったことありますでしょうか僕は幸いや幸い山ですそこは成敗ストーカーやったこと
がありまして
不審者とかやばい人に会ったときの恐怖感というのはわかってるんですけども
何してるかわかんないんですよ本当に開いて動きもわからずに素次に
ほんとこの三角も酢飯をな音してくるかわかんないんで一番て作ればいいのはその対象
動きを止めてしまう
それがきっとその危険な人とカフェの犯罪者とか不審者に行った時にやるべき
高度なんだと思います中田難しいですけどね実際やったらまずで怖くて体が動かないん
ですけども今回その訓練をちょっとしてみようと思います楽なんでし感とかそう言うな
がスケベな人も多くなるんでぜひ皆さんやちょっと身を守る術として国会見てもらい
たいと思いますこちら
ネットランチャー st スタジオは防犯機器でございますあのあれですねカッコ悪い
人がいたらこれがまた屋根のバーンと打てばネット
して飛び出て上がっ捕まる奴ですねポケモンとがでよくロケットながらピカって伝える
とかに使っているイメージがありません
あれです止め実物を初めてなぜで腕を持っている
まって今ないラインを待って会まずで買い手がいえっ
待ってくださいこんなでかいんですかまあ何かこれやばいって他の消火器的なアレだな
んだねかぷ切腹適切な使用によって生ずる
水小屋存在に対しては責任を負いませんで書いてありますうんで自己責任であります
犠牲者の動きによって複雑にか
何やって相手の動きを止めるってやつですねバーンといったらココ塗ってこうなっ
ちゃっ
強いはこれやりがちも勝ちも継手行為んだけど怖い待ってますね入って風邪から使えば
焚き付けけどばから助けて誰が指今回はちょっとこのネットランチャーが打たれた
この不審者が起き大勢になってどれくらいてにくいのかちょっと見てみようと思い
ます
ブーバーした
で本当による絢爛てるんですよネット参加の
な pikachu カマロサーモン&落とし穴つっ温い夏できる女性ってみようこれ
本当に
強さを気になってるんで行けたりちょっと打たれてみようと思います
いったーっ
ああああああ
me
[拍手]
[音楽]
今でやっぱり何がやはりないっ
はぁっ
右翼さんすごいでも
ってすごいし何かあっておらずどなったのねまでこれはいくつボックスほとんどだ
ええええ
[拍手]
ん
あと1個入りねっめっちゃいてんだこれたら今もずっと分かったことが一つありました
狭いところで打つとこういう形で絡まった家庭たぶんちょっとはないですよね犯人が
例えばないで今はもし本当に俺が苦戦者だったら終わってましたもうネットランチャー
なる広いところで打つと広角気味たいです次はずはちょっと綺麗な所じゃありません
で何分
何話で出ているのかこれで台でこれを使って逃げるまでの時間が分かるんだよかかって
みましょう
ねぇ
me
ああああああああ
[音楽]
yeah
衛兵
えーっ様からこれ
実戦だったらまずでわけよそうと戦国軟弱だったらこれちょっと言えてるんじゃないか
な
引っ張ったらそことかやばそうなんじゃないかがこのちょっと
がクイッタープチようにちゃんと仕掛けて使ってないと食べないでこんな感じになって
ターゲットの動きを止めるということでございます
うわぁこれじゃないのか倉木つこれやりですねたぶんうまくいったらこれ
いけますよ
よーいドン
うわっや衛兵うーん
まてっ
ねえええ
9秒48
子名
初産これ10秒じゃ何もできないですよこれ打ち方は無水には訓練すべきだと思う
勝ったとしての力
一発4ランドセンなんだよなるでしょ
me
me あった